no a helicopter cannot fly 90 degrees on
its side like that that's crazy hey fly
peeps i am bernice fliger alarmer coming
at you and back in 2003 i became
america's first black female combat
pilot serving two tours in iraq today
i'll be looking at helicopter scenes and
movies and judging how real they are
[Music]
attack helicopter on average can only
handle so much weight when i was going
in combat we sometimes we couldn't even
carry the full amount of fuel because we
were carrying more rockets and missiles
so the weight of that semi well is
beyond the two to four thousand payload
let alone the other vehicles that were
attached to it totally unrealistic
i think they were trying to simulate the
helicopter working so hard against the
vehicles to not be pulled
but that just wouldn't happen when a
helicopter is pulling more weight than
it can the engine isn't going to blow
out like that it's just going to slow
down the transmission and every the the
helicopter just won't be able to lift
it's going to drag it down but it
wouldn't explode
sir the weapons are back on nine goodbye
a missile or rocket actually has to arm
and there was absolutely not enough time
for a missile to be able to come off any
shot where you're going to shoot
something within 50 feet basically 50 to
100 feet unrealistic and if they did get
it off it's not going to explode it's
just gonna be a chunk of metal for the
most part that hits the ground and if it
did explode that shrapnel is the metal
from the ordinance is going to come up
and impact the helicopter which will
probably take it down
i'd give it a three
different missiles arm at different
distances but not within 50 feet
so the descending spiral happens when
there's more torque on a certain part of
the helicopter that's why there's the
tail rotor because if there was only the
rotor at the top the helicopter would
spin so the rotor at the back keeps it
from spinning so that meant something
was out of balance could he get it back
in control
yes absolutely
i didn't see any real reason on why the
helicopter was nose diving as soon as
you pull up and the rotor blades switch
position and it it should automatically
pitch the nose of the aircraft up
whether the engine is running or not
that just aerodynamically that's going
to happen why he couldn't pull the nose
up i'm not sure unless he had a
hydraulics malfunction in which the
controls weren't responding
but that wasn't the case because at a
certain point he pulled the stick up and
he flew off so
unrealistic
unless the guy is just a horrible shot
helicopters just don't maneuver super
fast
there's no way to get out of bullets
like that a helicopter doesn't react
like
a jet there's a little bit of a lag so
if i were to do the stick back and forth
my helicopter it would
it would rotate on its axis but it
wouldn't have necessarily had time to
move left or time to move right so you
would see it like dip and come back up
but it wouldn't have necessarily moved
out of the line of fire that quickly
just doesn't happen like with the jet
immediately it'll fly off to the left to
the right
yeah
no one would have survived that the the
cabin the helicopter the frame would not
even be intact by any stretch of the
imagination totally destroyed as soon as
the blades hit and it that showed it
rolling it would have been an explosion
the gas is end right inside of the heli
yeah no that's the impossible i guess
when your aircraft is going down you're
actually flying the aircraft down
there's this thing called an auto
rotation which when you have a fan and
it's just in the window and a breeze
blows through the window and the fan
starts turning that's the basics of a
rotor well when you're in the aircraft
and it's coming down basically falling
out of the sky let's say you've lost
power to the engine it's just a big fan
at the top so
a few feet above the ground you pull up
the collective while it's still flying a
little forward and that resistance can
cushion the landing in this case there
was no cushion there was no um
controlled descent it was catastrophic
there wouldn't have been anything left
i'd have to give it a one
you can't fly through something like
that
unrealistic
rotors would have already fallen off the
aircraft as hard as rotor blades look
they're very sensitive and finely tuned
and balanced and as soon as it impacts
an object you're not going to be able to
fly the aircraft after that hurry up
because it's the rock could have been
realistic with them hanging on the side
just like hanging on to a car right
because most of the downward push of the
wind from a helicopter is on
the last third of the blades it's not in
the in the very center so
the wind shear
wouldn't have pushed them out of the
middle
totally unrealistic it's just like the
wheel of a car it's never in one
position it's constantly moving where'd
he get the piece of metal to even fix it
when they showed it in that clip it was
just stable he's actually able to hold
it in the rod and
it's just not going to be stable like
that
no a helicopter cannot fly 90 degrees on
its side like that that was crazy i
would give it
a one
guns at the front of the attack
helicopters is that realistic absolutely
i had a 20 millimeter gatling gun three
barrel
it um rolled around and delivered
lots of bullets very fast on target so
yes 100 realistic only the pilots would
fire that weapon
you see two rocket launchers left right
then to missile launchers left and right
there are 26 rockets in each one of
those pods then there are four missiles
on the inboard that is actually a
standard payload for an attack
helicopter
the rockets are called 2.75 inch rockets
so they're about this big around right
2.75 inches
and they're pretty long the rockets are
just like bullets you you aim you shoot
you pull they go wherever wind shear
impacts them the hellfire missiles are
laser guided
right so they're guided by laser to a
particular target a rocket it impacts a
small area let's say it's 20 feet 30
feet these rockets are basically just
you know as soon as they hit they
explode and it's a point target the
missile has a lot more explosive power
to it you can shoot a tank or a building
it's going to explode there are heat
seeking missiles and missiles that can
fly
to catch a jet per se right but those
aren't the kind of missiles that number
one were on this aircraft and number two
aircraft um helicopters don't normally
carry them and
they don't
follow humans and i doubt his jet pack
had enough heat coming off because it
probably would have burned up his legs
if that were the case
[Music]
there would have been no way they could
just glide into
um going through the vortices of the
helicopter i could easily see them being
blown down 50 to 100 feet just like that
the payload that was actually realistic
the heat seeking missiles not so much
i'm gonna give it a seven
flying in formation in helicopters is
very common we practice it a lot we will
land together we'll take off together
and in an environment like this where
you have that mission where you're
dropping off say a flight of soldiers in
this case yeah that would absolutely
happen like that
just
everything about that combat maneuver
the insertion them dropping that's why
we don't do static things like that
anymore in combat because of the
vulnerability and the the helicopter has
pretty much no maneuverability when
you're in that close to be able to get
out really quick a helicopter just
doesn't move quick a helicopter has to
build up momentum and then get going
right rpgs are a huge threat to
helicopters
especially if we're flying what we call
low and slow but i remember flying in
combat and we just saw the and it was
early on in combat and i just saw these
great clouds of mist and we were trying
to figure out like what are those clouds
of miss and they were rpgs that had been
programmed to explode at 200 and 300
feet and some of my buddies were
impacted by rpg's huge threat
so the one i would say unrealistic part
of that clip when that rpg hit the tail
rotor of that aircraft
i thought it would have been spinning a
lot faster and it wasn't gliding down
without power and at the very end if he
tried to cushion the landing a little
bit which we're taught to do in that
kind of situation with the loss of tail
rotor we would have tried to circle
around in the direction that it's
spinning to have a little control but it
wouldn't have just landed flat like you
saw in that video so the guys in the
back hopefully they're tied in or they
would just immediately be thrown out
just like a car accident that twirls
over and everybody gets ejected out of
the vehicle the reason i think they
show or film more helos getting hit in
the tail rotor just because it's more
dramatic you get hit in the tail rotor
you're immediately gonna start spinning
and go out of control if you get hit in
the main rotor you just explode and fall
out the sky which one's more exciting on
a scale of one to ten
nine
my only thing would be right here why is
the hair why is the helicopter out of
control nobody's touching a pilot
they're just two guys fighting in the
back it wouldn't be hard to fight and
move around in the back of an aircraft
it would almost be like an elevator
without walls do not do a barrel roll
oh my god
an extended turn at a large degree it
would just have too much weight lost off
of the rotor
a helicopter is pulling on this small
little pole there always needs to be
weight on the rotor system from the
aircraft right so all of those little
barrel the railroad he did it at the end
and the inversion flight that's just
completely unrealistic for a helicopter
there is the red bull helicopter that is
capable of doing things like that but
for the most part 99
of helicopters out there
can't do things like this you would
never want to go past 50 60 degrees
i'd have to give
it a
three
[Music]
countries have different helicopters and
this was foreign like definitely had a
lot more
stability because it had those kind of
like semi wings right it could carry a
lot more
armament with attack helicopters here in
america we have the apache and the army
and the cobra in the marine corps very
similar it's like comparing the the
mustang to the camaro right they're
going to be a lot of similarities but
they're also going to be some
differences you'll see in attack
helicopters is you'll have the tandem
which is
pilot co-pilot front back
or you'll have side by side
as in the blackhawks and the apache is
actually tandem as well just like the
cobra
when you're flying a helicopter that
actually has what we call door gunners
right in the back the pilots know how to
maneuver the aircraft to get the target
in the right place for the door gunners
to be able to shoot at that target it's
rambo not sure how much training he's
gone through as a pilot right with door
gunners but you get him in position and
the door gunners take care of business
the crew chief would say come left or
come right or you know they would give
them very specific instructions
especially if their environment is
changing and it's over on the right side
but the left seat pilot can't see it
right so they're in constant
communication the entire time
i'll give it a six
yeah there wasn't much realistic about
that clip at all whatsoever let's say
the heat-seeking missile was coming
after us just when you shut the engines
off the engines are still hot so the the
hitsuki missiles would have still found
them there's no situation where i would
cut an engine off the rotors aren't
going to stop turning like that and just
the fact that it was flying through the
air the rotor would never be not turning
even if it didn't have power to it
they were
literally a thousand feet above the
ground you're not gonna get the rotors
turning again and then fast enough to
get the aircraft back in control
to be able to lift it up that was
completely 100 percent unrealistic a
helicopter is not like a plane so you're
not going to glide
a helicopter to helicopter combat is
just not common at all whatsoever
because when you think about helicopters
that's up close and personal troops in
contact the only time you've seen
helicopter versus helicopter is in a
movie like this where the bad guys are
chasing the good guys and that's it if a
helicopter is caught up in a dog fight
something has gone drastically wrong
because it just shouldn't happen we do
have training
but the training is actually focused on
a jet
chasing us
not another helicopter if we were to get
into a situation like that looks a lot
like what you see on the tv right where
you're yanking it to the left or pushing
the nose over pulling up on the
collective coming up flying around the
more you're moving around you're a
harder target to hit versus just a
straight line where they could track you
and then take you out of the sky
just helicopters are very vulnerable we
don't move that fast
so if you're caught in that kind of a
situation
the odds aren't exactly with you but all
the other tricks and things they did
just unrealistic this is
just gonna have to be a two
and if you enjoyed this video
click the link above to watch another
one